so Gumi you've given us a lot of tips
and things to think about is there a way
to just see where we are in terms of our
our account security
yeah um one thing I love that's evolved
in the industry over the last few years
is a lot of the tech providers have
developed very simple and easy to use
tools like a number of us have things
that are um like a security checkup for
instance and it's a simple place where
you can go to be like what are the top
things I need to look at to get my
security better and what is the state
that I'm in like for example some will
give you a score you know like you're 99
save or you could have a color like a
red green and yellow and so it's really
good to go into those and see what
specific things in your account that you
need to go and fix
that's super helpful I have to say I
thought I I knew this pretty well and I
do about 80 of what you've been talking
about but I I have a little bit of work
to do to tighten up my my account
security after this
yeah definitely and and you know like a
lot of companies including Google we do
a lot in the background automatically to
protect users and so when one of your
services actually
um tells you like hey there is something
to pay attention to you really should
because that's the last mile that they
need you to do in order to protect you
more fully super useful thanks so much
Gooby
of course thank you